what are the four different levels of
being a director again I'll preface
there's there's no higher level of
importance per se it's just like
um and maybe it's not a totem pole maybe
it's a
you know it's a hieroglyphic wall
that goes left to right
um but I think you've got you've got
short films
um
and web series
um and in that space you're you're doing
things that are narrative but they're
they're going to take less time
um at least on the production end you
you could have you could do a story film
that takes a great deal of prep but
typically just with the amount of money
being spent and the nature of of the
content I think you've got short film
and web series
um I think then you've got
um commercials and music videos and
branded content and those are
maybe the distinguishing factor to
consider is that your your
outright selling a product right like
you're you're selling this you know
lotion you're selling this
um
uh some of the stuff I did in on in my
day was like this kind of
sponsored
documentary profiles where a brand might
want to interview a bunch of people
about what they do but like that type of
person is their direct customer you know
what I mean
um so it's it's much more of a of a
clear intent to sell and then uh I think
you've got television which is obvious
and then you've got feature films which
are obvious but the distinction being
um it's the medium for the director and
features and it's the medium for the
writer in TV
um and I think you know I would I would
offer that
trying all of them and being able to
direct in all of them
is a great skill set to develop because
you never know when one of them will be
called upon so as an example I did
um
the fifth episode of the final season of
Silicon Valley and so it's just like
it's this whole
um
uh it was inclusive of an opening a Mad
Max kind of opening with Russ hanneman
and he's on a motorcycle and these women
in these kind of Mad Max cars are
chasing him and it's you know he's
blowing them up like with this hand
gesture or whatever and so
HBO being HBO was like oh let's go shoot
the thing so I was like oh we're gonna
actually shoot that so we took an extra
day outside of our production window for
the episode and shot that thing but then
there was also
um the characters sold a tequila in the
show called Trace Comas which the three
commas for being a billionaire and so
HBO and an ad agency partnered up to
actually sell that tequila so
the last part of that
five hour window where I sat the Mad
Maxine was getting like 18 different
lines of him selling the Vodka which
would be used for online commercials and
it was like oh
I got you they were like how I was like
I got this here's how we'll shoot it but
we'll motorcycle will pull up he'll step
off I'll get each line and you know I'll
get half of them in this shot we'll
reset I'll get half in that shot it'll
take us about 10 minutes and it was like
this thing I had done it's kind of a
running theme that this thing I had done
for all these years was like now
a very great asset for what I was doing
at that moment
um and even like you know a lot of the
documentary stuff that I did you'd have
to walk into a room and say okay
um I'm thinking of uh for My documentary
on on the black tankers 761st
we secured an interview with General
Colin Powell and we had 15 minutes of
his time and like that was like 14 plus
one to take a photo right and so got
down to Virginia and they're like you
can do it in this room and this room was
like the office furniture Cemetery
so in 20 minutes they're like get all
that stuff out of here let's leave that
chair all right we're going to gel the
windows I think I saw a flag in the
lobby let's go get the flag from the
lobby all right there's a plant and
doing that like has helped me with
production design when walking into a
location that
is a potential location for an episode
but
I have to Envision what it could look
like
you know before I can you know say I
think this works or not like we don't
everything we walk into isn't what it
will ultimately be so I feel like I've
left the the the the farm and entered in
another world here but I there are all
these like takeaways from each of these
kind of four types of directing
that I think help you in your execution
of each other one
sure and then also two managing stress
and also having the confidence to say I
can do that you know and I'm sure
totally different world you know being
in Virginia getting maybe security
clearance to go somewhere and and
interview this man right versus what
seems like it would be a really fun set
in Silicon Valley but I'm sure there's a
lot of moving pieces and just right the
pressure but saying yes I can do that
that's really cool
yeah I mean so many great directors
started doing product you know yeah I
think it's a I mean if you can tell a
story in 30 seconds you know and be
aware of who your audience is be aware
of what the brand thinks of itself
you know because that's really the
guiding you know the North Star for how
you need to choose your
production design your wardrobe your
frame composition like all those things
if you can do that in 30 seconds
that's one type of story you know then
if you can take that and you actually
understand
you know
human beings and their emotions and
their wants and needs and subtext I
think it's it's it just makes you
very capable uh at doing this job
how much time did you spend at each of
those levels
one thing I often say is I'm platform
agnostic so that that's the flip side of
like that's the end game of delivery
right like I don't care if it's TV film
I guess quibby came and went but I
thought that was cool you know like a
web is great with me like if it's a
story I'm interested in
where it ends up
fine with me
um
I have the same feeling for the you know
so-called levels that we're talking
about too like I would make a short film
next weekend if I had a script you know
um because they keep I love there's a
different challenge of short filmmaking
which is it's about an event
and
something well you introduce a status
quo you introduce an event and you then
are left to imagine how the world you
know resolves itself after this event
has impacted the protagonist world or
life
um so I would do that
next weekend in between directing an
episode of Television you know
um I'm writing a script now a feature
script
um I'm co-writing a heist script that I
hope to make you know as soon as I can
finish it between directing these shows
um and I still have a commercial agent
so I'm you know they all kind of coexist
to me
um but in the
in the
years where the goal was to get to TV I
would say it was you know feature
filmmaker
you know for well it was like feature
filmmaker and short filmmaker from 99 to
08. because I made my short they went to
Sundance I made another short that went
to a bunch more festivals in 04 I made
uh premium in 761st in that time so I'm
kind of jockeying back and forth and
then from 08 to
2015 I made
a couple web series
I made uh I didn't do any short I made
another short film that brought me back
to TV and I was writing feature scripts
all that time as well
um
and then now and you know let's say from
2015 to 2022 I've made a narrative
podcast you know that was going to be a
short film but with covet
um I couldn't personally absorb the
covet costs that would be
um
put on the production in terms of
testing and everything that would go
with that so I was like well let's do a
narrative version of it an audio podcast
and I'm very proud of it
um what's it called sorry it's called
Wednesday morning
and it's centered around uh it was like
a conversation around the 2020 election
but in a very surreal kind of discrete
charm of the bourgeoisie scenario
um and you know I got to work with my
wife who's an actor Kelly McCreary
um Coleman Domingo who's an actor
Spencer Garrett so it was great to just
you know the thing that I know I learned
from that project was It was kind of
easier to get people for the narrative
podcast
because it was and no one worked for
more than two hours
because it was like all right you're 12
to 2 in the studio and we'll get your
you know your character in this 50 page
script and we'll knock it out and so
that had my mind clicking of like I need
to write another narrative podcast
because then
that could maybe be something that
becomes intellectual property and then
can transition to a TV show like home um
like homecoming
um uh the the Sam esmail project
um
so anyhow I I feel like that for me it's
like
wherever a story can live
is the best place to put it and live
might be the different format you know
you might say well I can explore more of
this world or this character in TV
versus two hours with a film great you
might also be uh having to consider
money and so maybe the same idea and the
themes of that are better served in a
short film because you have five
thousand dollars and can make it short
which is better than an idea that you
just talk about so I think they're all
just like they're almost like lenses you
know like which lens is your favorite
well the one that gets the shot